I would like to call on behalf of Mr
khardi the president of Brazilian Arabic
Crescent through Sky News to call the
support of the European Union United
Nations and the International Community
in response to the devastating
earthquake that took place in Syria this
morning we can't really request the U.N
the EU and the Red Cross of Crescent
Society to provide a necessary like
great skills and support we hope that
this AUM will respond to this call for
support and text us to have alleviate
the suffering of those impacts by this
earthquake through crossline
interventions in its lab and direct
support in Aleppo and also we are
grateful for the National Society the
package of today morning and they
promised us to send an emergency
assistant
we know that that your your calls for
help are being heeded at the EU 10
countries at least have already said
that they will offer help they can
Germany the UK also saying that they
will do do what they can but of course
the problem for a lot of international
countries is that they don't have a
diplomatic relationship with Syria how
do you think you will get Aid in from
countries that are in dispute with Syria
and its leader
actually as a humanitarian organization
will work in partially impartially all
over Syria and through the beginning of
the crisis we were having a huge help
for all the countries through their
National societies and this is what we
are actually expecting today especially
the health sector have been destroyed so
today we are doing our best to help the
injuries and the wounded and even give
the emergency responses to the people
but this is not enough so that's why
we're giving this call to you